and now to the brilliant screenwriters
who applied their points of view to the
work of a Canadian author iconic movie
characters of the past a German war
novel a puzzle who'd done it and even a
Japanese film based on a novella by Leo
Tolstoy here are the nominees for best
adapted screenplay
All Quiet on the Western Front
screenplay by Edward Berger Leslie
Patterson and Ian Stockell based on the
novel by Eric Maria remark
gloss onion and knives out mystery
written by Ryan Johnson based on
characters created by Ryan Johnson
living written by kazuo ishiguro based
on the film ikiru written by Akira
Kurosawa shinobu Hashimoto and hideo
ogoni
top gun Maverick screenplay by Aaron
Krueger and Eric Warren singer and
Christopher macquarrie Story by Peter
Craig and Justin Marx based on
characters created by Jim cash and Jack
Epps Jr
[Music]
women talking screenplay by Sarah Polly
based upon the book by Miriam Taves
and the Oscar goes to
women talking
born in Toronto Sarah Paulie made her
big screen debut as a child in the
Disney classic One Magic Christmas
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
um
first of all I just want to um thank the
academy for not being mortally offended
by the words women and talking but so
close together like that
cheers
um Miriam Taves wrote an essential novel
about a radical Act of democracy in
which people who don't agree on every
single issue manage to sit together in a
room and carve out a way forward
together free of violence
they do so not just by talking but also
by listening
the last line of our film is delivered
by a young woman to a new baby and she
says your story will be different from
ours it's a promise a commitment and an
anchor and it's what I would like to say
with all of my might to my three
incredible kids Eve Isla and Amy as they
make their way through this complicated
beautiful world
um thank you to the best man I've ever
known David sanamarski for giving me the
optimism to believe we can and will do
better
DD Gardner and Francis McDormand thank
you for letting me stand on your
shoulders and making this space for me
we have the most incredible cast and the
most incredible crew some of whom are
here tonight please stand up if you're
there or if you're in the nosebleeds and
everybody at home who worked on this
film
oh my God I accept this on all of our
behalf thank you thank you wow